[Musique]
enfin les enfants marchent aux doublons
tu veux de bobos et oui nous avons ce
soir un vrai marchand de ballons je ne
vivent pas patron jeu layton ils sont
paumés neveu pour nicolas pour pas
preneur et pour tous mes amis
héros voilà
on est jeune homme
fait c'est soit tu fais tout mon petit
oscar et ne perd pas marchand de ballons
bonsoir les enfants tu veux de ballons
rouges et javi bien allons allons ne
vous bousculez pas les enfants une
minute voilà le plus beau hein pour
oscar c'est bien agréable d'être un bébé
tu te trouves pas de taux tu vois là
pour pape rhône elle loupe au loup
merci mon chéri pour nicolas legros
gk il est bien de lui manque solide pas
première est pour vous mes chers neveu
tenu
du passé à présent mais le veut vous
allez montrer à nicolas ya un problème
ce que votre oncle vous appris à faire
avec des ballons
1 2 et 3
sur la terre
c'est pas mal bravo les enfants
attendus ce n'est pas fini
2 3
sous le nez
du taux
attendu attendaient
2,3
sur l'horreur
oh
alors c'est vraiment calé ah oui
les bateaux non on lui quelle famille tu
viens tab rebelles
[Musique]
au monde et on lit
oui bonne nuit non à une bonne nuit les
petits
la g dans la gueule
à domont
panique à la fête pour f1 prône l
[Musique]
dépêche-toi nounours nous sommes en
retard voilà voilà pas trop or quelle
belle soirée ne fait pas tant de bruit
tout notre petit monde dort déjà
vous lis va
bonne nuit les enfants fait deux pour un
oh
m
où
au mans
[Musique]